hey D nice congratulations thank you
um I want you to take us back to the day
that you decided to do a club quarantine
what was the process like
um for you what was the thought process
like
um the process was me being at home
alone I was quarantined alone my family
you know in Michigan and New York and my
daughter was at away at school
um
and just being being a Home Alone
um just sitting there just
feeling a bit bit sad a bit depressed
because I realized what was happening
you know my gigs were being canceled
wasn't with my friends and family and um
I I just woke up that morning and opened
my laptop up and just wanted to feel
connected to people and just wanted to
play not even it wasn't even about DJ
and it was just me wanting to play music
and share stories with people and um and
it turned into what it did within like a
week man it's still kind of insane you
know all right here it is
team nice let's go let's go yes I want
to thank my family you see my mom and my
daughters are here with me
um thank you to my attorney thank you to
the CQ squad for always like being there
for me with support this wins for each
and every one of you thanks to ig and
that platform for making all of this
possible and it's been an honor an honor
to provide entertainment and inspiration
during one of the darkest times we've
experienced thank you all once again
this is D nice CQ for Life Entertainer
of the Year is a a broad award it means
a lot of different things each year when
it's awarded what does it mean to you
because you really did entertain the
world I mean it's the truest sense of
Entertainer of the Year and a follow-up
question who do you have for versus on
Easter Sunday
um uh winning um entertaining of the
year what does it mean to me you know
honestly like
when when I started doing this and and
um
I I received a an email or I'm sorry a
DM
from a from a doctor and and she had
sent me all these messages over and over
and over again and I had never read them
and when I finally read them all she
wanted me to do was to shout out a
patient so when I finally responded to
her this was like within the first two
weeks when I finally responded to her
and um she told me that the patient
listened to me every single night that I
was on and then she passed away
unfortunately
that was a hard thing for me you know
like and I just knew that
as for as long as that before as long as
we were going to be quarantined as much
as I could do it I wanted to just be a
source of inspiration to people you know
to even if it just allows someone to
just take their minds off of
um whatever they were dealing with for
30 minutes just to be in a chat it was
important to me so this is truly one of
one of the highest Honors that I've ever
been presented and it means the most
because I know what it really meant to
people and who do I have versus I'm
friends with I'm friends with you know a
couple of the members from Earth Wind
and Fire but
man I am an Isley Brother San like Ron
Isley can do no wrong in terms of making
music so I think I'm gonna have to I
mean it's a celebration of the culture
anyway but if we're going to the to the
kind of like the original battle sense
of light versus I'm going with the
isleys did often talk about the
importance of knowing how to read a room
when they're playing live or playing for
festivals and concerts how do you do
that virtually
that's a great question because it was
uh difficult initially but what I
learned is that this was the first time
in my career that I actually felt that
people were coming to something that I
was doing because they wanted to hear
what I had to play as opposed to like
you know when you when you're when
you're a DJ and you're playing a club
you tend to lean you know in the
direction of like how people are dancing
or or um but it's always it's always
like I call them like cheap party tricks
it's like you get to play like this is
how we do it or poison like because
those records automatically get people
dancing or Before I Let Go
I've been fortunate enough throughout
this journey to just be able to play
what I love and people have gravitated
towards us so my way of um kind of like
seeing where or engaging if people are
into it is obviously based on the amount
of people in the room but also the
comments and also Hearts flying like
when I see hearts on the side like
constantly going to me someone sitting
on a phone constantly pressing it like
yo that means that they really love what
I'm playing
foreign